bon joueur christian baulme merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
arte france comment se profile ces deux
derniers jours d'ouverture des commerces
dits non essentiels dans quel état
d'esprit sont les commerçants concernés
les commerçants font député mmm est
blasé à la fois offrant des bien compte
que la situation était intenable dans le
croissant ouest qui était très peu
infectés parce que les métropoles le
taux d'incidence est mis à flamber on
est passé de 195 à 450 en l'espace de
dix jours donc effectivement on santé
qui allait arriver
non mais quand même dépité parce que
notre vocation c'est d'ouvrir les aides
sont maintenus un bruno le maire nous
l'a confirmé hier soir dans une réunion
avec les acteurs du secteur et les
acteurs économiques donc enfin qui
promet donc vous venez de dire que les
aides sont maintenus mise en place
prolongé pour aider les commerçants
concernés
bercy évoque une enveloppe de 11
milliards d'euros s'était pas suffisant
vous savez c c'est un accompagnement un
ministre bruno le maire nous a dit nous
avons conscience que ce n'est pas assez
pour payer tout mais c'est un
accompagnement voit la bombesque un
accompagnement on a été entendu sur le
scot en est entendue sur
l'accompagnement alors maintenant reste
des mesures à prendre mais qui sont que
à l'europe pour vérifier qui ait pas de
distorsion de concurrence
on est en europe 1 quand même donc il ya
des mesures que le gouvernement ne peut
pas prendre comme ça donc le temps de
réponse de l'europe est plus long donc
on verra ce qui va arriver mais en tout
cas nous pensons que nous aurions dû
être confinés plus durement à la fin des
soldes pour reprendre fabre il
au plus tard parce que le commerce
redémarre à cette époque de l'année
voilà là il ya un creux entre
février-mars et donc c'est un temps de
retard mais on va faire avec
on va faire avec les tellines trous dans
la raquette des mesures que il faut
qu'on change la méthode d'attribution
des aides
c'est à dire qu'est ce que vous
souhaitez pas c'est à dire qu'on
souhaite la prise en compte du site
d'affaires annuel parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez des entreprises qui font pas
pendant la période de fermeture moins 50
de chiffre mais qui font moins 30 sur
toute l'année les -30 sur toute l'année
c'est insupportable comme depuis le
déclenchement des mouvements des gilets
jaunes on arrive sur des moins 10 - 15 -
20 selon les secteurs tous les ans de
chiffre d'affaires il faut à un moment
que on s'en sortent surtout dans les
métropoles
alors après il ya tout justement avec
ces nouvelles restrictions avec tout ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières semaines
et ces derniers mois depuis un an même
combien de commerces selon vous son
menacé de dépôt de bilan elle est ce que
vous craignez une équité sociale alors
que 20% des commerces qui peut tout
appris ça fera pas d'un coup d'un seul
ça va se faire humble
ils s'affaiblissent peu plus en plus
donc il va y en avoir de plus en plus
les cats home sociale elle a déjà eu
lieu en partie dans le monde des
commerces
puisque nous n'avons pas embauché en
décembre tous les ans qui sont qui
partent ne sont pas remplacés nous
n'avons pas embauché pour les soldes
donc finalement on fait des économies
puisque après le loyer dans les
métropoles c'est le deuxième point de
deschacht et comment est ce que vous
accueillez les le calendrier
de sortie de crise fixé par emmanuel
macron échance repoussée à la mi-mai
pour une réouverture de certains lieux
comme les terrasses des lords et reste
une carotte inatteignable ou un objectif
réalisable renoncer c'est un objectif
c'est un bel objectif ça nous fait
plaisir d'entendre ça mais on sait que à
trois semaines personne n'est capable de
faire des prévisions parce qu'on ne fait
pas le virus lui dit pas qui va faire
accroire même donc le gouvernement comme
les autres ont dit on prend la part du
risque entre eux voilà en mettant les
gens en état de moins se rencontrer et
en vaccinant on va arriver au 15 mai à
un tout qui permettra de faire oui ok
c'est de la 4e' stick médina
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous avez eue bruno le maire qui vous a
confirmé que des aides allaient être
prolongé on rappelle l' enveloppe 1 11
milliard d'euros sur quatre semaines
mais est ce que vous avez eu des
discussions avec les syndicats ou avec
des conseillers de bercy avant
même ses annonces de restrictions pour
les modalités de réouverture notamment
de ses commerces
alors on est en relation permanente nous
alors la panne fin en relation
permanente avec le même temps d'économie
de finance un lapin c'est que depuis le
mois d'octobre nous nous discutons des
stocks
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des surplus de
stock des invendus comment valorisons
dans les bilans tel incident tado avoir
parce que ça coûte aux entreprises et
les comment dire les commerçants savent
alors compter sur la valorisation de
leurs actifs en fin d'année donc c'est
important un sujet très important
vous voyez les sujets tour l'ont alors
on discute avec eux et ils traînent en
compte alors on n'est pas écouté entendu
chaque fois mais on espère l'être le
plus souvent possible
merci christian bohn d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association commerçants
et artisans des métropoles de france